[Music]
Anthony I often get asked this question
if scientists actually knew that there
was an impending catastrophic collision
some asteroid was heading towards earth
would they tell you and the answer is
yes we actually study the sky every
night we're looking for objects that
might be on a collision course with
earth and if we find anything that even
looks risky we inform lots of people the
other thing is that the sky is available
to anybody on the earth no one
government owns the sky there are
telescopes everywhere on the planet
there's no way that anybody could hide
the fact that some big asteroid was on a
course with the earth
so one of the things that I find very
difficult as a scientist is people often
ask the question would scientists tell
us if something really bad was about to
happen and he think about that sentence
and you have to ask the question who is
the US here am I not part of us I
remember back I think it was in in 2012
there was this idea that the Mayan
apocalypse was going to come that the
world was going to end it was all over
the news and I actually got a phone call
from somebody I was sitting at my desk
at NASA and somebody asked me the
question you know is the world going to
end next week and I thought about that
because of course we knew that the world
was not going to end there was nothing
happening astronomically that we could
tell but I realized this person didn't
think of me as an actual human being
that if I knew the world was going to
end in a week I would be at work at my
desk I don't think so
the day you have all the scientists buy
up all the great wine and max out their
credit cards and disappear then you
might want to worry but even that's not
how we work we are people and if we knew
something dangerous was coming there'd
be no way for us to hide it now one of
the things that NASA is researching
right now is how to actually alleviate a
bad collision if we see a big asteroid
coming toward us on a collision course
there are actually many things we could
do to avert the a story a little bit
haven't missed the earth and we're
studying those right now but in the past
whenever we've even seen something that
looked slightly risky we've gone to
the government about it we've gone to
people we've gone to the press we have
nothing to hide and this is something
that is really difficult in my life
people are saying are you hiding aliens
are you hiding evidence of this are you
hiding the fact that an asteroid is
gonna blow us up or whatever and to me
it speaks to the separation that somehow
scientists are this monolithic inhuman
group that we could hide things that we
would want to instead we've been trying
to involve the public and everything
that we do I know this will not convince
the conspiracy theories out there but
one of the things I love most about our
science is how accessible it is and how
much we would tell you even if something
bad was going to happen
[Music]